For this one, we'll have one square root of 5 plus one square root of 5. We
simply add the coefficients in front of the radicals together, to get 2 square
roots of 5 or 2 times the square root of 5. We do the second one in a similar
way, to add 3 and 1 to get 4 times the square root of 2. Here, we're
subtracting the same quantity from the original amount. So that would make 0.
If you need a little bit more convincing on this one, keep in mind there's a 1
in front of each of the radicals, so we can rewrite this expression by
factoring out a fourth root of x. We'll have 1 minus 1, which we know equals 0
and 0 times anything is 0. For the fourth one we subtract 1 from 3 to get 2
times the cube root of a times b. Here, are the indexes of 3 match and the
radicands are same ab, this means we can actually subtract the two radicals.
And finally for our last one, we have 1 root of 3 plus 1 root of 3 plus 1 root
of 3. This gives us 3 roots of 3, or 3 times our square root of 3. I know these
are pretty tricky, so great work if you got at east three of them correct.